Brussels Belgium the epicenter of hue
politics here almost 4,000 miles away
from Washington politicians from all
sides are looking evermore anxiously
across the Atlantic the American
presidential campaign has left them with
nothing but questions what is the future
of the US soldiers in Afghanistan in
Iraq what exactly are your ideas to
fight Isis what exactly are your ideas
to deal with Russia there are so many
important questions I would like to see
discussed in the US election
presidential campaign but obviously
we're talking about email accounts of
mrs. Clinton and love affairs of mr.
Trump not only in political circles but
all across the continent Europeans are
shocked by the tone of this year's
presidential campaign especially that of
mr. Trump so it's hardly surprising that
according to opinion polls if Europeans
had a vote Hillary Clinton would win by
a landslide it seems like firm still has
a chance to win and for most Europeans
he seems like a sociopath just clearly
not a good candidate it's one election
that's made for that European aren't
very used to where the choice really
matters the outcome really will change
and have a possible impact on on the
world
I can't imagine Tom Ben being president
of the United States and if I don't know
I wouldn't know what to say really I
wouldn't know what to say but it's not
just about the tone of the campaign
substance matters to both Clinton and
Trump have attacked the current
administration's free trade agenda and
negotiations on the proposed
transatlantic trade deal TTIP have
already run into this and my message to
every worker in Michigan and across
America is this I will stop any trade
deal that kills jobs or holds down wages
and then there's the issue of security
Europe depends on there
closest ally in dealing with Russia and
the Middle East but Donald Trump has
already made clear under his leadership
the US would be prepared to walk away
from old alliances if Trump wins that
will be a major wake-up call for the
Europeans because they will have to
think international policy in a
completely different way Trump on this
one has been very clear if he were to be
elected he would be a much more
isolationist much more nationalist
president so that would not be a good
message for the rest of the world Europe
has always taken a close interest in
u.s. presidential politics any reset of
the transatlantic relationship matters
but this is a year unlike any other as
the closest ally heads to the polls
Europeans here in Brussels and all over
the continent are watching closely